et bing challignac où es tu sais que
demain mais devant efficace à nous la
liberté vaut sympa avec moi je lui est
entre de bonnes mains
un peuple n'est pas plus qu autant qu'il
est libre pour la titine matin sa ville
taurine ensemble ouais c'était une
structure ton point de vue tourisme
structure quand tu suis cocoa willy la
peine 8 heures du matin je lui tends jus
d'orange feu avec ou sans dix mois ils
font pas mal tu charme d'un domaine des
boutons c'est un diagnostic de a été
cédé je traduis crise de puberté à
retardement être mustier non coupable
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien le made in china tout est
fait en chine a son terrain
franchement est-ce éclabousse j'en ai
pas
[Musique]
toujours nous quitter son domicile
depuis hier soir 19h face à ma douleur
d'une fugue louis 34 ans
[Musique]